moments of high-speed panic
in a battle often heavy with long
stretches of silent tension Isis mortars
explode nearby an american-backed
fighter exposes his fists to attract a
sniper's round it works this is a battle
for the heart of the so-called caliphate
for its capital Raqqa fighting in this
landscape for the SDF the Syrian
democratic forces is going to be all
about momentum they simply don't have
the troop numbers to hold this vast
amount of territory here in the west of
the city the fighting is ferocious and
it has to stay that way they need to
confine the so-called Islamic state to
another smaller area of territory and
prevent those counter-attacks but in the
long term it's the Kurds that are doing
most of the fighting here and in the
long term they will not be welcome to
stay for now the focus is on winning the
battle for Raqqa it began with the
capture of the tadka dam by the SDF in
an air assault in coalition planes soon
fighters led by female generals were
closing in on the city itself
hooking south along the Euphrates from
tadka and simultaneously punching along
the main roads into the city from the
east the north and west tens of
thousands of refugees have fled through
their lines and most of the isis
leadership is believed to have run to
the south into desert villages now under
coalition air attack keeping the advance
going has been grueling Isis just
launched a counter-attack using tunnels
the extremists got behind the SDF lines
a positive spin can't hide this setback
we got about another kilometer further
forward before we were chased out by the
Syrian democratic forces and coalition
special forces because the situation
here is extremely unstable the
infiltrators have not all been cleared
out a Kurdish commander has told me that
there are several pockets where the
infiltrators have pinned down some of
the SDF fighters they have wounded and
they have dead and at the moment they
have no way to get to their rescue and
one of the lessons of this is that there
is no formal frontline in urban warfare
and we've seen in Mosul just how long
the battle for that city took it is
hoped that the battle for this city
could be quicker but there are three to
three and a half thousand foreign
fighters still in the center of Raqqa
and the lead American diplomat in the
region Brett McGurk has said they are
all going to die here
but Syrians fighting Isis are now
looking to a future in Raqqa beyond the
cult Laila Mustafa is occurred and the
co-president of an administration in
waiting for Raqqa
she says Syrians who worked for Isis but
did not kill will be pardoned Wasel
added elephants Regina an Illuminati
inna allaha so many martica
of regional women are talk gorillas and
me on scene with rational that may not
convince the city's majority Sunni Arabs
that liberation from extremism will not
be replaced by occupation by rival Kurds
that is a problem for now that has been
shelved Sam Kiley Sky News Ratner